[Music]
on this friday night commitment and
cooperation strengthening ties between
canada and nato in the face of potential
threats what happens here matters not
only for canada it matters for the whole
alliance new revelations and
explanations in the trump search
affidavit why the fbi wanted to scour
his florida home and what's still a
secret the canadian screen awards goes
gender neutral the concerns about
inclusion leading to exclusion and
highlighting an issue with many shades
of gray it's a very controversial
territory the gamble brands are taking
to fire back at misogyny and ageism
global national with bara nasser
[Music]
good evening thanks for joining us
canada's arctic is in the strategic
spotlight tonight as nato's chief caps
off in historic three-day visit to the
region underlining its tactical
importance to the alliance today prime
minister justin trudeau and nato
secretary general jans stoltenberg
toured four wing cold lake in northern
alberta after visiting a radar warning
station in nunavut on thursday the visit
a show of solidarity as canada and its
allies seek to fortify the far north
and counter an increasingly hostile
russia wielding a new generation of
weapons
is
an increasing concern to all of us
makes it timely for us to
share
with
the secretary general and with nato all
the things that canada is doing through
norad
but also independently to make sure that
we're
protecting
this
region
russia has set up a new arctic command
it has opened hundreds of new and former
soviet-era arctic and military sites and
also using the high notes as a test bed
for their most advanced weapons
including hypersonic missiles
stoltenberg and trudeau took direct aim
at the russian president's invasion of
ukraine and the challenges exacerbated
by climate change for shifting the
geopolitical climate and as eric
sorenson reports accelerating arctic
security concerns
it is called the north atlantic treaty
organization but it now sees the arctic
as a new front on the geopolitical map
for decades canada has partnered with
the united states through norad to guard
the north
but the visit this week by nato's
secretary general is a clear if informal
sign that the alliance is a partner too
what happens here matters not only for
canada it matters for the whole alliance
there is no
deep shift in canadian policy we are
proud members of nato we will continue
to work with nato in everything we do
why now
climate change is making the once frozen
arctic much more accessible to friend
and foe alike and russia's war in
ukraine has crystallized the threat that
russia now poses with hypersonic weapons
for which canada must modernize its
defenses to ensure that we're not
setting ourselves up to deal with
historic threats but really making sure
that we're working with our allies to be
able to deal with emerging threats with
sweden and finland joining nato seven of
the eight arctic countries in the world
are now with the alliance the eighth is
russia and canada's location is crucial
directly across the arctic ocean from
where russia is expanding its northern
military capabilities plus china is
extending its reach into the arctic
escalating security concerns for nato
beijing and moscow have also pledged to
intensify practical operation in the
arctic
this forms part of the deepening
strategic partnership that challenge our
values and our interests stoltenberg did
not address that canada falls short of
spending two percent of gdp on defense
as nato members have agreed to do the
billions that canada has committed will
take time to upgrade maritime and air
defenses including new f-35 jet fighters
that are at least three to five years
away from being delivered the goal
ultimately is deterrence have the
ability to convince the russians not to
do it in the first place and the only
way you're going to do that is by
demonstrating that you can detect them
and that you can respond to them as this
country deepens its ties with nato
expectations for canada's military
readiness in the arctic will also grow
erik sorensen global news toronto
we're getting our first look at the
documents used to authorize the fbi
search of donald trump's florida home
the u.s justice department unsealed the
affidavit today and it was heavily
redacted but it did hint at serious
evidence the former president took
highly classified documents from the
white house our washington bureau chief
jackson prosko now with what else we
learned
the search of donald trump's home was
prompted by deep concern about what
documents the former president was
holding onto the unsealed affidavit
redacts specific details used to
authorize the search the fbi argued
there was probable cause to believe
classified national defense information
was being kept at mar-a-lago along with
evidence of obstruction of justice
it seems unlikely that any judge would
have issued a warrant for a former
president's home if it hadn't been a
very strong case the investigation began
after a referral from the national
archives the affidavit explains the 15
boxes of documents trump returned to the
archives in january contained 184
classified documents 25 marked as top
secret including material that could
reveal u.s intelligence sources
officials were alarmed because the
sensitive material was casually mixed in
with newspapers photos and miscellaneous
items from trump's presidency
yet the justice department believed
there was still more classified and
national defense information scattered
throughout mar-a-lago including in
trump's office and residence
the august 8th search ultimately
recovered another 20 boxes including
multiple sets of highly classified
documents a potentially significant
breach of national security
we'll let the justice department
determine that we'll see what happens
in a memo explaining its reasons for
redacting so much information the
justice department warned of risks to a
significant number of civilian witnesses
with concern trump or his allies might
take steps to interfere in the
investigation
still unknown why the former president
held on to documents he had repeatedly
been asked to return trump is now
personally attacking the judge who
authorized the search warrant as he
complains about the extensive redactions
to the affidavit part of the reason why
the fbi says it wants so much kept
secret is that it says it's still trying
to locate potential criminal
conspirators in this case as it searches
for outstanding evidence
farah
jackson proskow in washington thank you
jackson
and u.s prosecutors are seeking formal
authorization to offer a plea deal to a
quebec woman accused of mailing poison
to donald trump
a draft plea agreement has been
discussed with pascal ferrier's lawyers
it would address three charges she faces
in washington and 16 charges in texas
ferrier is currently being detained in a
washington area jail officers swarmed
her apartment in 2020 after she was
accused of mailing envelopes containing
ricin to the white house and several
texas law officials ferrier is scheduled
to be back in court on sunday
a new cache of documents obtained by
global news is shedding light into how
the canadian armed forces grappled with
reports of its members taking part in
february's so-called freedom convoy
emails detail concerns over the
involvement of some of canada's most
elite military members with senior
officials choosing to launch an
investigation into the matter our ottawa
bureau chief mercedes stevenson is
following this developing story for us
jtf2 is canada's elite counter-terrorism
unit tasked with missions of the utmost
national importance including the
targeted killing of high-profile
individuals deemed to be terrorists and
performing hostage rescues when senior
members of the military discovered at
least three members of the
ultra-secretive unit were participating
in or supporting the convoy they
launched an investigation
documents obtained by global news show
the military was aware that members of
the unit were involved and expected the
story to snowball in the media two
members of jtf2 participated in the
protest and appear on social media
condemning vaccine mandates global news
has learned that a jtf2 officer was also
transferred out of the unit after it was
discovered he had donated to the convoy
financially online sources say the two
members who participated in the protest
have since been released from the
military in february major general steve
boivan the commander of the canadian
special operations forces told global
news if the allegations are accurate
this is wrong and it goes against
canadian armed forces values and ethics
cansofcom does not condone its members
supporting and or actively taking part
in causes that jeopardize the apolitical
imperative associated with their
functions members of jtf2 are not
allowed to participate in political
demonstrations or espouse
anti-government messages because they
must be prepared to respond to any order
the government of the day gives and
sources say that could have included a
response to the protest if national
security threats had materialized now
cansofcom is refusing to comment on why
the two members were released or
disclose the findings of the
investigations in a statement the
command says upon learning of
allegations that members of the canadian
special operation forces command
supported the freedom protests in ottawa
investigations were initiated the
results of the investigation will not be
further discussed in order to respect
the privacy of the former canadian armed
forces members the pandemic put
tremendous stress on jtf2 like it did on
so much of canadian society and more
than a dozen sources with direct
knowledge of the unit say that the two
men in question who have since left the
military were highly decorated had
excellent service records and one was
even involved in that historic longest
sniper shot in iraq but things changed
when the vaccine mandates came in and it
created significant social splits in the
unit which have created questions about
culture and operational effectiveness
both of which many of the operators in
that unit say the command needs to
address
pharah
mercedes stevenson in ottawa thank you
mercedes a group of volunteer scientists
and public health experts that have been
advising the ontario government on its
coven-19 response will soon be dissolved
the ontario science table was told by
the province's public health agency that
its services would no longer be needed
by september 6. now this news comes
after the resignation of the group's
longtime co-chair dr steiny brown in a
statement the table's scientific advisor
wrote the pandemic will remain a
daunting challenge for the foreseeable
future and hopes the principles the
table was based on will live on in some
form
two household names from the pandemic
are now embroiled in a lawsuit moderna
is suing pfizer and its german partner
biontech for patent infringement madra
alleges pfizer copied technology that
was developed years before the pandemic
to develop the first coven 19 vaccine in
2020 murderna said it would not enforce
its clovid19 related patents while the
pandemic continued then this past march
with vaccine supplies improving globally
it said it would update that pledge now
it's not clear what damages modern is
seeking the lawsuit has been filed in
both u.s federal court and in german
court
the concerns around europe's largest
nuclear power plant coming up why some
experts say the danger is being
overblown plus
fears of what's in the forecast for
rain-ravaged pakistan
europe's largest nuclear power facility
is back online today after temporarily
being disconnected from the power grid
amid ongoing shelling near the zaparisia
plant ukrainian officials are now
reportedly handing out iodine tablets to
local residents as fears grow over a
potential nuclear incident in the region
but as redmond shannon reports some
experts are taming those concerns and
suggesting things at the plant aren't as
grave as they're being made out to be
ukraine says zaparisia nuclear power
plant has now been reconnected to the
grid after these fires which it says
were caused by russian shelling took it
offline on thursday
territory
president vladimir zelinsky said it had
risked a global radiation disaster but
nuclear experts say that is an
exaggeration
all this uh is kind of a fear mongering
and both sides needs electricity
so that's the reason that the plant is
still there and operating and uh
and they will need electricity hopefully
also in the future
nuclear engineer professor leon season
says there are multiple backup systems
during a disconnect and even in the
event of a meltdown this type of power
plant would only affect a 20 to 40
kilometer radius
on friday russia said it took out a
ukrainian howitzer gun that was
targeting the plant the same model that
was supplied by canada both sides have
accused the other of shelling
it's difficult to verify any of those
accusations but last month ukraine
released video of an airstrike against
russian forces just 300 meters from the
reactors the proposed visit from
independent inspectors would need all
violence to stop kiev
accepts it
moscow accepts it we need to go and we
are going to be there hopefully very
very soon one former nuclear inspector
told global news the terms of that visit
will decide what the world might learn
the hosts are going to take them to see
what it is they want them to see
it'll be interesting whether the
ukrainian people who are running the
plant will be allowed to interact with
the iaea and show them what they want to
show yet no matter how low the risk may
be to the wider world it's little
comfort to those who live close to
europe's largest nuclear power plant
redmond shannon global news london
as the war drags into its seventh month
its effects continue to be felt across
europe the uk's energy regulator says
households can expect their annual bill
to increase by 80 percent in october in
part due to a reduced supply of russian
gas the latest hike will almost triple
what households were paying last october
there are calls for the government to do
more as fears grow of an affordability
crisis in a nation that's experiencing
its steepest inflation rates since the
80s it comes as analysts say russia's
state-controlled energy giant gazprom is
burning off an estimated 10 million
dollars of natural gas a day adding to
both environmental and energy concerns
in the region
and pakistan has declared a national
emergency after a devastating monsoon
season
record rainfall has triggered flash
floods across more than half of the
country pakistan's national disaster
management authority says 943 people
have died since june including
343 children the floods have also left
more than 30 million people without
shelter pakistan's minister for climate
change says the country is going through
its eighth cycle of monsoon more than
twice the normal amount
data suggests there could be another
cycle in september
ahead going neutral why the canadian
screen awards is doing away with some
prominent categories
you're watching global national
there are some big changes underway for
one of canada's most prestigious events
recognizing top talent in film
television and digital media next year
the canadian screen awards will drop
gender-based categories so no more best
actor or actress just best performance
until now some trans and non-binary
actors have been shut out of contention
but as dan spector reports some
advocates say there's still a long way
to go
and now the nominees for best lead actor
comedy it is our pleasure to present
best performance by an actress phrases
you will not hear at the 2023 canadian
screen awards canada's version of the
oscars and emmys
the academy of canadian cinema and
television has decided its awards for
excellence in acting and movies and tv
will be gender neutral for the first
time starting in 2023 the ceo says it's
all about being more inclusive when we
talked this through with different
stakeholders we felt like this was the
the right move to move towards inclusion
young kids actor marissa mcdonald
doesn't identify as male or female and
they say the move was long overdue i was
so
so excited for
not just myself and my community but the
future of the generations to come after
me to see themselves reflected on
authentically
both mcdonald and emmy winner jovan
nicola appreciate the gesture but the
two are among several actors with major
concerns for one there are now fewer
awards to win instead of five nominees
for each gender in each category there
are now eight in total i don't think
that's fair uh
to women actually and or to lgbtq
non-binary and trans people because
the reality is is that it's not an equal
playing field in the industry the actors
wish the academy would have just added
more categories giving more people a
chance to shine in an industry where
it's difficult to climb the ladder you
know best male performance best female
performance best non-binary performance
best transgender performance this is
very important to gig workers this is
part of the
the opportunities we have to put on our
resume to build our career the national
president of actress says another major
issue is that writers and producers are
still not creating enough roles for
marginalized people it's just not there
yet i feel like we only change the
culture by expanding the kinds of
stories we tell and by creating better
opportunities and more visibility for
people in the lgbtq community
the academy says it's open to adding
categories in the future and hopes the
move illustrates that people from all
backgrounds are welcome in the industry
dan specter global news montreal
next marketing gray zone should brands
jump on hot button social issues
to die or not to die for so many women
and men around the world it's taken the
pandemic to ditch the hair dye and
finally embrace the gray hair
they say it's energizing and empowering
but after bell media's recent dismissal
of respected canadian journalist lisa
leflem some big brands are firing back
tonight karen lieberman looks at the
campaigns calling out sexism and ageism
and speaks to women who've gone back to
their roots and are showing their true
colors
and i just noticed that beautiful streak
right there and i just i love that
as stephanie george approached age 50
she made a choice it just wasn't worth
the time anymore to cover up the route
i'm happy to show my grades this week
fast food chain wendy's canada swapped
its mascot's recognizable red-haired
pigtails for gray ones
tweeting because a star is a star
regardless of hair color one of the
latest brands to back former ctv news
anchor lisa flam whose dismissal by bell
media raised questions about sexism and
ageism throughout the pandemic gray hair
has made headlines in many top
publications with the new yorker calling
the phenomenon silver linings and others
suggesting ditch the die
at this toronto hair salon there's been
a notable increase in the number of
clients embracing their gray by the time
that seven eight months that we were
closed and nobody get a chance to color
their hair their roots were out and they
actually see how beautiful their gray
was same in hollywood and on red carpets
while social media response to recent
marketing campaigns has been mostly
positive some experts warn the move can
be risky for certain brands
dove maybe a little more because they
have done some work in the past with
women's issues wendy's i'm not so sure
they have the authority to do that it's
a very controversial territory when
brands start to jump in on social issues
when hot button issues don't align with
a brand's focus
where brands get into trouble sometimes
as they try and show up in a
conversation in a way that seems a
little bit opportunistic
because deep down is not really who they
are
stephanie george would like to see more
support for aging women who show their
true color not just when it's convenient
the whole patriarchal system of our
society where men can go gray and it's
distinguished and women go gray and they
just look old
it's hogwash karen lieberman global news
toronto
that's global national for this friday
night i'm farah nasser on behalf of our
whole crew here i want to thank you so
much for spending part of your friday
evening with us tonight's your canada is
okanagan lake in penticton british
columbia we love seeing your canada so
please keep emailing us those photos to
viewers at globalnational.com
tracy tong will be with you on the
anchor desk tomorrow until monday take
care of yourselves and each other have a
restful weekend good night
[Music]